on
à
1 2 3 4
il fait un froid de canard aujourd'hui
qu est-ce qu aux normes du commissaire
malgré une prise de bec est mal tourné
le pauvre type s'est fait canarder ya
laissé des plumes tulle cervelle de
moineau
voilà voilà voilà
de toute façon y'a quelqu'un sur le coup
daigle non un pygargue je sais que c'est
une erreur classique de fond les gens
parce que en anglais ça s'appelle le
rideau et regardez ces deux photos ça
c'est un eig ça c'est un pygargue oui ça
parlait d'abord parce que ça fait
l'aigle de la nuit bon où est la victime
marcher dessus
ah merde c'est un suicide
c'est ce qu'on a pensé au début ensuite
on a trouvé ça dans sa poche
je me suis dit que c'était important un
jeu vidéo
quelle étonnante et inattendue
découverte
fa s'ouvre vous êtes un génie
je vais mettre ça dans mon canard pc
vous aimez les jeux basés sur les comics
on a à peine effleuré la surface elle y
en a tellement
en même temps quand un développeur de
jeux vidéo c'est juste parfait il ya une
distance qu'il prenne part de réfléchir
il ya les gentils les méchants et
combien de la baston du coup tu as le
gameplay déjà tout près alors on a déjà
vu pas mal de jeu tiré de la licence dc
comics mais déjà on après tout vu et
ensuite on n'a pas encore vu mais jeu
tiré de la licence marvel et je sais pas
pourquoi mais de jeu marvel y en a
vachement plus et là pour le coup il
n'en n'oublie aucun meuble héros les
plus improbables comme howard the duck
sur commodore sorti en 1986 est un jeu
ou en sauvant sur une île perdue pour
tabasser des indigènes des ressources
naturelles m'appartiennent mais je suis
sûr qu'il avait cherché comme les
indiens alors la grande majorité des
jeux tirés de comics sont plutôt moyens
voire correcte mais sans plus
en général c'est de la plate forme
horizontale on tabasse des ennemis en
avant cinq ans par exemple spider man
web of fire sur 32x
alors la 32x si ça vous parle pas c'est
juste une tentative désespérée de
prolonger la durée de vie de la
megadrive
le jeu commence par un écran bien badass
qui profite des capacités techniques de
la 32x
mais par contre se passe quoi avec le
son de l'intro là
donc daredevil a été capturé et la ville
a été envahie par une [ __ ] de rave
géante
alors donc on on va parler du jeu alors
la première chose qu'on donne c'est la
beauté des graphismes et la fluidité de
l'animation beinerman ressemble vraiment
à spider man in control répondent
correctement mais on notera quelques
petits problèmes de l'île bosse mais qui
n'entend pas le plaisir de jeu alors
concernant les ennemis pauvre je dirais
que bon ben ça va on retrouve les
ennemis les plus connus de marvel comme
dégueulasse or le premier boss en gros
un indispensable pour les fans
plus sérieusement le jeu une pas
horrible mais il est plein de problèmes
déjà il est vraiment très dur pour
commencer tu vas régulièrement te manger
un ennemi que t'as pas je veux dire et
ensuite
spider man et comme aspiré par les
surfaces dès que tu croises un mur ils
se sont obligés de marcher dessus même
qu'un simple compteur électrique mortels
et à aller en mer c'est bon on a compris
que marcher sur les murs arrête de te
suicider pour nous de montrer mais c'est
pas ce genre de jeu qui va nous
intéresser aujourd'hui et avant d'aller
voir les jeux tirés de la licence marvel
on va retourner voir un des derniers
jeux de la licence dc qu'on avait oublié
un jeu qui est souvent cité comme étant
un des pires jeux avec superman 64 c'est
batman dark tomorrow alors déjà
commençons par ce qui est positif le jeu
un scénario plutôt pas mal et des
cinématiques de relativement bonne
qualité pour de la gamecube
les graphismes sont ma foi pas choquant
pour l'époque mais en fait avec ce genre
de jeu on a l'exemple typique d'un bon
gros et rond bien puant posé sur un joli
coussin rouge ont commencé le jeu en
affrontant trois petits voleurs à il
faut les mettre au sol et ensuite leur
passé les menottes est bon ça l'a vu
qu'on affronte les bandits là les plus
polis du monde ça pose votre problème au
début de m je comprends c'est que je lis
tu as un serment femme écoute c'est le
coeur
une fois les voleurs arrêtés oracle vous
dit de vous rendre ailleurs et donc vous
arrivez sur toi et là la purge rectal
commence [ __ ] de merde le gameplay du
grappin est horrible un bon jeu c'est
censé être intuitive je devrais pouvoir
comprendre les contrôler facilement
je veux dire je connais la touche du
grappin alors nom de dieu pourquoi t'as
fait ça je suis la justice non mais
sérieusement c'est mon kiff débile ou
bien là comment ça marche
alfred pouvait venir me pousser mais en
fait il y avait un piège parce que je
m'étais trompé au bout de plus de 20
minutes d'essai j'ai finit enfin par
découvrir que je ne dois pas utiliser le
grimpeur mais le bad câble parce que
dans le monde étrange de batman d'arturo
le grappin c'est celui qui va comme ça
et le bas de gamme c'est celui qui va
comme ça rien à voir 1 oui c'est comme
cette peine regarder c'est laid ça à
boucher les trous et ça laissera les
creuser un avoir le sus
allez vous faire [ __ ] par après c'est
pas parce que tu as le bon câble que ça
va aller mieux entre la caméra qui fait
n'importe quoi et les murs invisibles du
pif absolue [ __ ] avait mais [ __ ]
mais ça doit être aussi compliqué pour
batman de passer sur l'immeuble d'en
face quoi la moitié des gens du quartier
ont vu m'écraser sur leurs fenêtres
et maintenant que vous maîtrisez ça vous
allez enfin pouvoir commencer à vous
battre contre leurs ennemis du jeu
jean-michel cadrage caméras caméras de
caméras je crois qu'il est plus sur
l'écran
l'eau le cadrage bref finalement après
30 minutes de souffrance on arrive aux
batignolles pour voir le commissaire
gordon batman et donc on commence la
vraie première mission qui nous permet
de voir l'autre côté du jeu
l'infiltration est ce qui vient de tirer
sur la caméra
enfin bon peu importe parce que batman
dark moreau ça n'est pas qu'un mauvais
jeu d'action c'est aussi un mauvais jeu
d'infiltration
quand vous appuyez sur z vous marchez
plus lentement ce mode est censé être le
mode infiltration comme d'aller
maintenant actuel qui me permettraient
normalement si c'était bien fait de
mettre au sol les ennemis discrètement
sauf que je peux pas les rattraper
comment je suis censé arriver dans leur
dos ils vont prendre plus vite que moi
marchand regardez les trois quarts des
trucs ça se passe comme ça vous arrive
est derrière un ennemi et il faut
distance mais c'est complètement
ridicule moi même je vais trois fois
plus vite que sans rampe en commun non
[ __ ] de merde et c'est complètement
aléatoire les ennemis vont alterner
entre la grand mère aveugle et le demi
dieu omniscient enfin je veux dire là je
cours derrière ce type de voiture
m'explose à la bouche vingt mètres
derrière lui il se retourne pas mais par
contre ceux là vont m'entendre me
relever derrière un immeuble avec des
sirènes de police qui hurle partout
enfin bref de toute façon on laisse très
vite tomber la filtration pour foncer
dans le tas parce que ça va bien plus
vite et que s'infiltrer avec cette
caméra de génie oh là là mais me filme
pas moi [ __ ] les ennemis sont à
l'angle de la rue je les vois sur la
carte film les oeufs et on connaît dans
la caméra comment est ce que je dois
trouver ça je veux dire c'est pas un bug
on a vérifié donc ça veut dire que c'est
un choix artistique
vous êtes sérieux qui a faut graver ça
il est important de savoir à quel moment
lynch il sourit je vais passer sur les
longs moments du type [ __ ] de merde je
dois aller ou qui constituent la
majorité du jeu et c'est pas la mini map
qui va t'aider à vue qu'elle ne sert
absolument à rien à part pour le délire
de dessiner les trucs que fut avec le
trajet de ton perso trois tracés ma
position de secondes batman
je suis dit mais bon alors la musique
j'en parle pas vraiment la plupart du
temps des régistres une musique de
relaxation pour salons de massage du le
reste passe de l'affolement brutal quand
tu croises d'un ennemi à l'arrêt total
sans aucune transition
le jeu a une dizaine de niveaux alors au
début ça s'enchaîne assez vite mais à
partir des trois quarts du jeu ça
devient un vrai lavage d'intestin à
partir du niveau dans les égouts qui
dure une éternité tant les ennemis qui
deviennent plus forts qu'ils deviennent
20 fois plus nombreux à dire une
agression dans le métro l'appui prenez
mon téléphone et foutez moi la paix et
la super idée des menottes aussi qui
devient nul à chier parce que les mecs
qui te tape dessus pendant les
cinématiques de menottes
les petits bugs qu'ils ont rajouté un
peu partout jour là je galère parce
qu'ils ont oublié d'animer la descente
et des escaliers mais descend [ __ ]
j'essaye de sauver gordon a évidemment
l'inévitable niveau avec le deltaplane
lé vol vers ton destin de merde [ __ ]
est-ce qu'une raison au moins est ce qu
une raison pour laquelle je tombe comme
ça c'est scientifiquement impossible
bordel de merde
il ya un moment il va falloir arrêter de
mettre des deltaplanes dans les jeux
vidéo est la cible du moment ça marche
pas venir à sonic sur master system
batman dark tomorrow sodique sur master
system et le pompon sur le gâteau c'est
qu'après des heures à jouer à cet
horrible merde à tourner en rond a pas
savoir où aller
quoi que tu fasses à la fin avait razak
bull détruit la planète et tu auras une
mauvaise fin parce que le seul moyen
d'avoir une bonne pincée de désactiver
un signal de merde dans l'entrée bien
hors champ et bien caché quand tu
rentres dans la salle juste avant le
méchant et que absolument rien du tout
dans le jeu ne t'indique qu'il faut
faire mais si vous êtes des gens cully
c'est quoi le but de faire sa part de
perdue elle jeté biannic et à jouer pour
rien atteint bref fin du jeu le tanneur
de ra's al ghul explose et les 300 mec
que tu avais menotté parce que tu es le
chevalier noir que tu personnes eh ben
ils meurent tous dans l'explosion et
voilà encore aucune victime pour le
chevalier noir
bonjour canard man je vois que tu as
passé le premier défi il est temps de
passer à la suite
mais d'abord attendez une seconde cebs
de plus tu peux arrêter de télécharger
il ya les machines écoles pardon désolé
je t'attends maman labyrinthique et
norman fait des pêches pas vite
les invités sont déjà là
cet endroit jupiter et pluton seront
tous les deux en bel aspect cela vaudra
un bon potentiel de chance qui vous
permettra d'améliorer vos revenus
jupiter et pluton ça marche
merci on va rebondir et nous met dans le
piège que voilà dans des salles
spécialement sortir d'une hormone
prochain que de finir mon défi je t'aime
bien kahn avait comme le tien tu y
trouveras et télécommande pour changer
le décor de ton joie et je dépose et un
coca sur la table ça du tout ça en fait
je suis parce que j'ai pas le choix
du coup c'est pas mal mais cas classique
c'est parti pour dix en khâgne x men
sorti sur nes en 89
édité par l j n bref après le choix de
niveau le plus austère que j'ai rarement
vu le jeu commence est ok alors les
barres de vie les indications l'histoire
le nombre de vies tout ça ressemble rôle
qui a besoin d'une interface c'est
vachement plus pratique d' appuyer sur
start à chaque fois que tu veux voir des
points de vie d'ailleurs c'est comme
l'histoire je veux dire c'est sûr fait
là ça sera en direct l'histoire
d'après la texture du sol je peux
clairement dire que par exemple ce
niveau est tiré de x-men contre les
steaks hachés alors le premier truc déjà
ce jeu est une poubelle visuel c'est le
cimetière de la beauté vire gardois 7
dégueulasserie chaque niveau est une
oeuvre d'art qui redéfinit les concepts
de la mouchetée je vois je veux dire
c'est quoi cet endroit c'est quoi ces
machins est-ce que ça me tue je suis ou
là dans l'anus du méchant maintenant les
niveaux où tu comprend à peu près que
c'est censé représenter un vaisseau on
dirait que ça a été construit par un
architecte fuyao que game design design
vraiment gagné non plus en fait je veux
dire mais regarde moi cette zone de
merde qu'on dirait que mon jeu il a
planté il ya aucune transition dans les
décors je passe de lustucru zone à
salins alors donc vous pouvez choisir
votre héros avant le début de niveau
vous avez le choix entre wolverine
tornade colossus cyclope diablo et
iceberg est évidemment il n'allait pas
sans culé la vie pour créer des vrais
perso et on ajuste donc des swaps kohler
pourri sur les sprites du tiers-monde
colossus ressemble à captain planet
tornade ressemble à tina turner dans mad
max 3 et wolverine sans ces [ __ ] de
griffes
comment vous faites pour louper ça je
veux dire c'est littéralement le premier
truc que tu vois sur n'importe quelle
image de wolverine et comment il faisait
chez les jeunes c'est quoi leur
technique commerciale fait je veux dire
il faut arrêter toutes leurs licences
mais il réussit c'est quand même à
toutes les choper à les signer non
on d'accord dans bref donc ses héros
sont séparés en deux genres ceux qui
tirent et ceux qui ne tirent pas inutile
de dire que dans un jeu où les ennemis
arrivent à l'infini sans aucune pause
apparaissent au milieu de l'écran et en
sautant partout
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je foot
avec un héros qui ne peut que taper au
corps à corps alors si en plus tu
ajoutes sur certains montrent que les in
box ont complètement buggé mais regarde
tout ça je le touche pas très deux jeux
[ __ ] je suis colossus et je ne peux
pas tuer ressort merde alors au début
effectivement le jeu te propose de jouer
à un ou deux joueurs parce que le jeu
peut se faire à deux en coopératif
mais quels amis vous avez invité pour
jouer à ça si vous le faites quel genre
de vie vous êtes ça dit de venir chez
moi passer un très mauvais moment
adama fois je te sers un grand verre de
pis en fait cela dit ne vous inquiétez
pas si vous n'avez pas d'amis ça n'est
pas grave a précisé même un petit peu
mais appeler en tout cas l'ordinateur
pourra jouer le second personnage pour
vous ah voilà je me sens tellement moins
seul maintenant c'est un peu comme si
mon ami handicapé mental à qui manque un
bras jouer avec moi je n'ai pas de mots
en français pour exprimer le degré de
stupidité de l'ordinateur qui contrôle
le deuxième joueur je veux dire vous
êtes obligé de vous le farcir mais il
est incapable d'éviter les ennemis
incapables de toucher les ennemis ils
marchent sur absolument tous les [ __ ]
de pièges et il est pas foutu de passer
la moindre porte sans mourir mais reste
bas la [ __ ] tu vas crever dans la
porte est debout franc mais sa 4
secondes quatre secondes c'est le temps
qu'il faut pour aller du début du jeu
jusqu'à la première porte et se rendre
compte que l'ordi il arrive pas à passer
les portes y aurait eu un testeur qui
auraient testé le jeu pendant 4 secondes
il se serait aperçu qui est un problème
parce que oui les ennemis les mutants
c'est bien beau tout ça ne parle pas
assez des portes
je veux dire les ennemis malev quasiment
pas de vie remet tout change peut rester
des minutes entières à me faire masser
la prostate par des groupes de monstres
mais par contre les porte tuant deux
coups super idée prenons une ia qui
tombe dans tous les piéger mettons des
portes qui tue en un coup c'est ce que
me faire participer des aveugles koh
lanta [ __ ] je passe vraiment un moment
délicieux mais il dégage mais qu'est-ce
qu'il fait plus tard
mais c'est pas vrai il me coincé dans la
porte et se suicide après cette autre
tarder mentale quoi est d'ailleurs
évidemment les portes bouge de manière
aléatoire pas besoin de chercher le
rythme d'ouverture de la porte y en a
pas heureusement que les ennemis lâche
régulièrement un item d'invincibilité
temporaire qui te permet de passer les
portes
j'utilise l'invincibilité pour passer
des portes puisque venus à parler des
ennemis mais allons-y je veux dire allez
sérieux maintenant on pouvait le dire
zeppelin sprite au hasard pour faire les
ennemis un par la tension une roue à
papillons un ananas jetables laissez moi
tranquille [ __ ] de but vous voyez
policiers de sauver le monde
ce jeu il est tellement moche qu'on le
testant on savait même pas comment se
parler fais gaffe aux horodateurs avec
un espèce de soutif sur la tête
tu veux parler de la cyber coccinelle ou
du truc qui ressemble un calamar halonen
bref donc on a évidemment tout le roster
de l'absence d'imagination les araignées
les scarabées les ressorts les ressorts
sérieusement comment ressort peut
devenir un méchant dans un comics
effia tu veux jouer non bref évidemment
ce jeu en plus il est dur les niveaux
sont labyrinthique et dure une éternité
j'ai joué des heures sans croiser le
moindre bosse à aller d'avant en arrière
à ramasser des clés dont j'ai pas le
moindre indice de leur utilité vu que
j'ai croisé aucune porte avec serrure
lire ce jeu non seulement il est pas
amusant mais en plus ils creusent y
creuse c'est la spéléologie du fun que
c'est la mort de la joie
je suis désolé magret c'est trop tard
pour moi que norman je me confie canard
city malgré vous commencez à me gaver
avec ses blagues neige de la nuit dont
le big air bordel regardez j'ai un chat
nathalie kosciusko morizet pillards
c'est pas compliqué plus tard oui c'est
le moment pour partir
les gauchos les décombres qu'est ce
qu'on fait maintenant
je vous ai quoi se double en caoutchouc
abeba les abattent appel
m
c'est ma maison je soutiens sociaux
de plus
c'est prendre la porte
si vous êtes vous avez de porte de
vanves vous avez de rendre une mort
lente et douloureuse et l'autre vers
votre ami malgré mais seul un cerveau
supérieur sera capable de résoudre cette
énigme
je suis un oiseau à tête blanche
cheville en amérique du nord symbole des
états unis depuis 1789
je suis un genre de rapaces dur qui se
nourrit majoritairement de poisson issu
du latin moment signifie littéralement
qui allait presque blanche
qui suit
j kosciusko morizet
bonjour si vous regardez cette vidéo
c'est que vous avez confondu nathalie
kosciusko morizet avec un pygargue à
tête blanche
ça n'est pas grave l'erreur est commune
mais regardez ce montage qui va vous
expliquer les subtiles différences que
vous n'auriez même pas soupçonner
majestueux volatiles qui volent par delà
les immenses étendues en egypte du nord
si sa tête nous est familière c'est
parce qu'elle représente le symbole de
la toute-puissance de l'un des plus
grands pays du monde l'amérique mais
pourtant ce n'est pas nathalie kosciusko
morizet c'est le pygargue souvent
confondue à tort avec la candidate à la
mairie de paris en 2014 qui pourtant ne
partagent peu de points communs avec lui
le pygargue henin pas un politicien
alors maintenant rappelez vous quand
vous verrez ce bec jaune et se regardent
persan vous ne penserez plus nathalie
kosciusko morizet vous penserez pigs
ça vire plus tôt
chassés d'eau
mais jamais
non
aller plus haut
mais je suis seul dans l'univers
j'ai peur du ciel et de l'hiver j'ai
peur des fous
ma gueule j'ai peur route on y pense
oui
peut-on vivre
normal d'achat attention